- I do want to get to why
you want to talk here today.
It's important to me as well,
actually my husband
and one of my really good friends, Eva,
we've been talking about this because
she's in LA holding our house down for us,
and I'm like, don't go out
- Yeah.
because it worse for African-Americans.
And and where are you right now?
And how is quarantine
going for you though?
- The quarantine is going good.
And you're actually absolutely
spot on right Kelly.
It's, you know, it's funny when you start
to think about the ratio and
population of black people.
We only make up 13%
which of course makes us minority,
but it's 33% of COVID
patients are African-American,
and some of the more African-American,
goes across, you know,
the virus comes,
and it's so many different types,
and I don't,
it's just so mind blowing,
but 30, that's a big number.
33% of patients are African-American,
and we have to get that number down.
And I don't know what's making
people feel like either,
it can't happen to them,
whether they're in the
African-American community or not,
but you have to take this seriously,
because one thing happens
like right after another,
which is oh you go out,
your friend has it,
your friend gives it to you,
you give it to Grandma,
then IT then this person,
then those people give it to someone else.
That's how it spreads so fast.
- Yeah.
And we just have to take
this way more serious
than you got to think about
also the illnesses from
high blood pressure,
high cholesterol, hypertension, asthma,
so many different illnesses
that have been really generational.
You know, illnesses in the
African-American community.
- And you have those,
- Yeah.
getting COVID, it becomes so worse, yeah.
You know, we just want to
be smart about all this,
and I just really want to
encourage everyone to stay inside.
We're not quite done with this.
But we can be,
if we really practice our
social distancing and have,
I like to say kindness.
Because when you actually
approach this with kindness,
then you'll think about the fact
that I don't want this to happen to me
and let me just be kind.
Stay in my home and be
smart about all of this.
How do you handle it?
- No and be kind to others.
so please be respectful to others
because maybe you have
an okay immune system
and maybe you might be
fine but first of all,
I do love a level of invincibility.
People think they're invincible.
Like they watch and they're
like oh that happens to someone else.
I'm like, you could be
that someone real quick.